Платити за газ у рублях. Таке зажадав Володимир Путін від європейців у відповідь на санкції проти Росії.
Велика сімка навідріз відмовилася. Адже це порушення чинних контрактів.
Оплата в рублях неприйнятна, і ми закликаємо відповідні компанії не виконувати вимоги Путіна.
Спроба Путіна внести розбрат у наші лави очевидна.
Але, як ви можете бачити, ми єдині у своєму рішенні і не дозволимо йому розколоти нас.
Речник Кремля Пєсков згодом додав: "Немає грошей - немає газу".
У Європі такі погрози лише долили олії до дискусій про ембарго на закупку блакитного палива у "Газпрому".
Німеччина почала реально готуватися до відключення російського газу,
а після цього Путін почав задкувати і у телефонній розмові з канцлером ФРН Шольцом намагався пояснити,
що просто пропонує нову систему оплати: коли гроші надходять "Газпрому" у валюті,
а непідсанкційний Газпромбанк потім конвертує їх у рублі.
Західні експерти розцінили це як неготовність Росії втілювати свої погрози в життя.
На мою думку, можливість, що Росія припинить постачання газу, існує, але ми ще не дійшли до цього.
Якщо уважно подивитися на заяви Москви, можна побачити, що простір для маневру ще є.
Поки не ясно, у який період часу постачання газу мають бути переведені на рублі.
Експерт додає, що поки ціни на газ ростуть, зупинка поставок до Європи нашкодить і самій Росії.
В умовах санкцій продаж енергоносіїв залишається суттєвим джерелом коштів для Росії.
Тим часом Німеччина, яку критикують за відмову запровадити ембарго на російські енергоносії,
гарячково шукає можливості, як відмовитися від газу з РФ.
Міністр економіки тиждень тому прозвітував про перші успіхи.
Залежність від вугілля з Росії була знижена за контрактами на постачання з 50 до 25 відсотків,
від нафти з 35 до 25 відсотків та від газу з 55 до 40 відсотків.
Ми дуже багато досягли за останні чотири тижні.
Ми очікуємо, що до літа 2024 року ми станемо значною мірою незалежними від російського газу.
Вугілля та нафту з Росії Німеччина замінити зможе,
а от із газом насправді все складніше, вважає експерт із газового ринку Гайко Ломан.
Частка поставок російського газу знизилася з 50 до 40% у січні та в першому кварталі цього року.
Але це все ще 40%. І втрата 40% газових поставок одразу створить величезні проблеми.
Це безпосередньо стосується всіх газових компаній, постачальників газу,
це, ймовірно, призведе до потреби раціонувати природний газ, принаймні для промисловості.
Ми підготувалися до цього певним чином. Але підготовка не значить, що ми зможемо пом'якшити удар.
Якщо Росія все ж таки перекриє газ, ціни на блакитне паливо злетять до небес.
Вже нині ціна на природний газ у Європі досягла 3500 доларів за тисячу кубометрів.
Ростуть і споживчі ціни на товари та послуги. Звідки тоді Європа братиме газ?
Частиною рішення є зниження попиту на газ та перехід на альтернативні джерела енергії.
До цього закликають і кліматичні активісти, які нещодавно влаштували ходу в центрі Берліна.
Вимагали відмовитися від "кривавого газу" Путіна.
Але однією енергією вітру та сонця швидко проблему не вирішити.
Ми мусимо значно швидше нарощувати виробництво енергії за допомогою альтернативних джерел.
Потрібно підтримати цю сферу. Це та ціна, яку ми маємо заплатити зараз і якнайшвидше.
Друге - ми маємо робити все можливе для економії енергії, особливо у житловому секторі,
де це відбувається не так швидко, потрібно навчати відповідних фахівців.
Наступної зими нам доведеться розраховувати на вугільні електростанції у разі відключення газових.
Ще один вихід - шукати нові джерела поставок.
Єдині постачальники газу, які зможуть поставити його у значних обсягах,
це учасники міжнародного газового ринку, такі як Катар, США, можливо, Австралія,
де в майбутньому можна буде видобувати більше природного газу.
Особливо в Катарі попит на природний газ значно зросте з 2026 року.
Цей газ доведеться доставляти до Європи у зрідженому вигляді.
Щоправда, і зі зрідженим газом можуть виникнути проблеми.
І це заторкне також і Україну, яка купує газ в Європі.
Ринок LNG-газу сформований, додаткових обсягів немає.
І відповідно той обсяг, що буде постачатися на європейський ринок,
це означатиме, що десь його потрібно забрати.
А десь - це виключно два таких регіони - найбільше це азіатський регіон і латиноамериканський також, меншою мірою, але він також присутній.
Питання наступне: чи хтось нам віддасть, тобто не нам, а європейцям, а європейцям це означатиме і нам.
Також під питанням опиниться статус України як держави-транзитера.
Поки що, навіть попри війну, російський газ безперешкодно постачається українською трубою.
У нас немає окремої газотранспортної системи для транзиту і для внутрішнього транспортування.
І щоденно ми транспортуємо для наших українських споживачів майже 80-90 млн кубометрів газу.
Наше завдання в першу чергу - транспортувати газ для наших внутрішніх споживачів.
Наявність транзиту для нас дає додаткову гарантію того,
що агресор не буде цілеспрямовано знищувати нашу інфраструктуру,
я маю на увазі газотранспортну систему України.
Росія навіть справно платить Україні за транзит - оплату за березень оператор ГТС отримав.
Якщо поставки в Європу припиняться, не буде й додаткових грошей у бюджет.
Але українські споживачі точно не залишаться без палива, запевняють в компанії.
У нас є власний видобуток 50 млн кубометрів на добу.
У нас є імпорт - 9 млн кубометрів на добу.
У нас є підземні сховища, які можуть видавати весь необхідний додатковий обсяг газу.
Тому якщо Україна споживає 80 млн, ми будемо ці 80 млн брати з власного видобутку, з імпорту, або з підземних сховищ.
Ніяких проблем немає, від транзиту це не залежить взагалі.
Більше покладатися на власний видобуток радить і експерт Юрій Корольчук.
Ключовий аспект стосується, я думаю, і Оператора ГТС, і "Укргазвидобування" - компанії, яка видобуває газ,
щоб на тих територіях, де вони займаються виробничою діяльністю, не було ніяких воєнних дій.
З досвіду попередніх років, можливості, ресурс, обсяг видобутку, який є,
він нам дозволяє здійснювати ту закачку газу і мінімізувати закупки з ЄС.
Бо ми бачили, що торік, коли йшла закачка газу і була дуже висока ціна на ринку,
тоді пам'ятаєте, ціна 1700 доларів сягала, то ми практично не закупили нічого тоді,
ми буквально трошки закупили, бо висока ціна була.
І нам вистачило власного ресурсу, який був закачаний.
Вимогу Росії до Європи розраховуватися за газ рублями українські експерти називають шантажем.
Москва продовжує звичну тактику - використовує енергетичні ресурси як зброю.